cheap mall that would be and that would
be hurtful oh yeah have you ever tried
to hit on a girl and then you get hurt
I've done that just to like my buddy's
like oh man you didn't get lay man just
go like talk to like that girl over
there who's obviously like not that
attractive and like she still rejects me
yeah dude wait you can't wait for girls
to go
yeah like Silicon Valley you know you
know Silicon Valley it's it's an it's
interesting most of the really cute
girls that come up to me are like oh my
god my boyfriend loves Silicon Valley
can we take a picture for him you know
what I found I don't know when you were
MADtv if you feel the same way what I
find is the girls that find me
attractive but they don't woman watch
Silicon Valley and then they find out
myself come out later then I'm really in
it mm-hmm you know that's a good that's
good
right yeah yeah like what happened a
couple of times yeah because that's the
best cuz I went to do watch Silicon
Valley so oh man I used to so I used to
use some of those dating apps I still
have it but I don't really use them yeah
this is like maybe last two seasons ago
in Silicon Valley and I was on bumble
met this really cute girl she's from
like Orange County beautiful right just
moved up him like perfect you know she
said she was a fan of Silicon Valley I'm
like we're in man her out to this
Japanese restaurant wrote a nice
restaurant right by my house and I'm
like hey you wanna you know go get a
drink after and then she's like let's go
back to your house I'm like oh went back
to my house which it's the same shitty
apartment I live in now yeah and then
with chillin drinking some wine you know
Mike man I'm you know this is good to go
like yeah and then she was like let me
check out your bedroom I'm like okay
yeah
[Music]
I don't know with chillins bedroom I
don't like it I'm like okay like I'm
just gonna let her make the most she
seems pretty aggressive yeah okay I look
in your closet yeah I was like what she
seriously like start like shuffling
through my closet I don't know like
she's like aspiring like costume
designer I know I'm back to the couch
like with chillin like and then you know
like I feel like okay this is my chance
I went in for the move you know and then
she's like whoa whoa I think at the
wrong idea
I'm a costume and that's why she said
and I'm like wait what what like you
would you were the one that want to come
back to my house you wouldn't want to
want to go to my bedroom I want to check
out my closet yeah till today I don't
know what her intention was and as she
left as if I [ __ ] offended her and
like never hit me back oh my god that's
what I was gonna hate hey lady if you're
[ __ ] listening right now
you [ __ ] [ __ ] scum you [ __ ] you
should have sucked his dick it's like no
I think that's she's [ __ ] weird she's
it if I proposed to a guy that we go
back to your place that's what's
happening because I was very gentle I'm
like let's go get a drink
like I wasn't trying to rush you know
and the fact that she was like you've
got the wrong idea you gave me that idea
yeah
I don't know what I think so now out of
my deduction from talking to my buddies
so it's a couple of things postgame talk
it's always the best way yeah so it's
either like she's a big fan of Silicon
Valley literally she's treating me like
an episode MTV Cribs cameo yang very
good Yeah right and then and then just
not interested or I Drive the [ __ ] Prius
I live in a shitty apartment if I was in
a mansion it would've probably at
different I don't know I don't know
those are my two conclusions a lot of
girls and I want to say this and maybe
I'm wrong all right but I'm here all
right
I may be wrong all right
50 55 million situations where like a
white girl in her dimension of thinking
she would never hook up with me so she
just assumes that I assume that that you
know that that I knew the house right uh
so we're hanging out she there's no way
that this fat asian guy even thinks that
you know that we could [ __ ] so we're
best friends already
yeah why would he think that look at me
and then when you make a move they're
like are you [ __ ] kidding me what the
[ __ ] you doing and then you're kind of
going oh you think that I'm like you
know a mythological creature from a
movie right I am right you're right that
and just happy to have you as a French
[ __ ] cuz I fury 800 for sure its I
feel violated after that you know it's
it's because it I don't give a [ __ ] what
you look like dude yeah to go from
working in a cubicle to doing stand-up
to getting on an HBO show doing two
lines and then having them go we want to
do more for this guy and to get a get on
on a regular basis is so difficult to do
that to me that that alone should make
you at the top of the food chain it's
interesting I think people are
interested
I think everyone's interested they want
to at least hang out yeah right
because I am on a TV show maybe they
like or maybe they just like who is this
guy and yeah like I think it's it's
interesting even when they don't watch
the show and they see they're like oh
man Jimmy can I take a picture with you
or something like on the street not that
it happens a lot what do they see
somebody do that they like who is this
[ __ ] I want to know more all
right but that is still being interested
it's still different than being
attracted to somebody right so I think
if for me it's better off to find the
people that are actually attracted to me
for just me anyways regardless of the TV
show and the TV show thing and just plus
and that's that's a way easier way like
yeah I fully agree with you
what you're about to say you've been
there you have you've done this like
what do you think he's always used his
work to parlay you know I cannot and I
might be wrong all right all right
is that why they don't want the sound
effects to yourself I think that's the
problem
yeah yeah this guy's a [ __ ]
eight-year-old retail no I've always
used um I feel like the harder I went up
the more [ __ ] I was gonna get and that
could be wrong right but um I I still
believe this is to this day I don't
think that if I wasn't in show business
that I would ever get the caliber of
women even in the inside he may because
kalila is attractive but her insides are
an amazing she's like the overall it's a
high school a week yeah we're like best
friend of soul mates yeah that's you
know we're best friends you know and uh
how did you guys meet tinder oh but let
me say something she looked at my
profile oh yeah he's a comedian
oh she knew who you are yeah she's not
gonna look at my profile this guy works
at Home Depot right I'm gonna [ __ ] go
right there's no one right but whatever
you're just a guy that has a nice job it
doesn't matter it I don't have the the
just the first look of it if I didn't
have you know credits I don't believe
that they would swipe right mmm but
maybe it's that self believe that Lisa
was swiping right because now you kind
of have leave right and from now on dude
you should put it out there up front
Jimmy single everyone know I put it up
front man yeah you mean but I just don't
know then it becomes like I don't know
what
they want it doesn't matter what do you
mean what do you think is this dude it's
like when people go yeah I don't know if
they're like dating me or they're using
me because on this is that if a girl is
gonna hang around like okay you know
your own smells right sure your [ __ ]
fart right your feet smell you have a
bunch of character defects that are like
kind of weird and somebody has to
[ __ ] endure that [ __ ] right right
no one's gonna endure all your [ __ ]
and your smells and your character
defects if they ultimately don't like
you right because she has to smell
things on me this she's never smelled
before that's correct right true love I
have a foot disease foot fungus just
know I had a foot fungus right that will
melt wax that's how strong it is yeah
like I'll take my shoes off on an
airplane and half the plane will go oh
yeah you know they'll make noises you
know my foot itches one time or [ __ ]
edge because I think I each to my foot
my fingers and I finger-banged her and
she got my foot fungus in her [ __ ]
that's correct right
that's so let me ask those are [ __ ]
factual facts sure yeah so my point is
is this she's still with me right so she
has to be a lunatic yeah to endure years
of just emotional abuse and physical
smells right right she ultimately loves
me that's great all right so what I'm
saying to you is is this even if they're
with you at first because you're on a
show if they stay with you it's gonna
turn into love yeah because I think that
that part is just going to pique their
interest
this guy's talented he works hard there
are certain things that as a woman is
attractive to me someone who's very
funny talented works at their craft and
is ambitious as and has had some type of
like success in what they do right
that's really all it is that's really
that's what piqued the interest
initially I could have gone to the
coffee and been like this guy is
absolutely obnoxious I hate the
way he smells he's disgusting and I'll
never see him again I'm not gonna
compromise like my happiness just so I
could be with you know this comedian
right mr. live with someone for four
years like I have with him yeah I mean
just because he's a comedian that's a
[ __ ] lot to do to my soul yeah I I
don't think it I'm saying like oh man
there I'm with them to use me I live in
[ __ ] apartment I don't think anybody's
trying to use me yeah but it's those
stories like a closet story that I was
telling you guys it's like a waste of my
[ __ ] time yeah but the thing is is
this you opened it wrong
what do that because you probably acted
like in upfront even in the dialogue of
the bumble map right in that [ __ ] you
there's a where were you to have
dialogue write to each other right even
in that right you have to be aggressive
not like I'm gonna [ __ ] eat your
[ __ ] but right but like you know I
think you're like soup you know oh
you're so attractive and you seem like
you know me you know you get that [ __ ]
out there right right right
to know that you sexually don't go hey
buddy
yeah you want to get coffee you like
sushi yeah I will say that it does
happen to to every single guy because
you know our real estate agent how cute
is he he's a cute [ __ ] [ __ ] very very
attractive guy but he Larkin yeah he was
telling us shout out to Mike a lot to my
Greek you [ __ ] the same thing basically
happened to him
weird you know he thought that this
girl's very pretty he took her out to
dinner there was a lot of interest by
the time they got to dinner she just
racked up a bill of like $200 at sugar
fish-like didn't even say a word to him
just ate and then left you know and that
just [ __ ] just happened what's wrong
with these people about to do to to
these women that's women are using all
these women and their [ __ ] of ultras
bro they're hungry for sushi do for
sushi clothes apparel all right and she
was going through your closet to see
what you can steal bro you think so not
on thanks yeah man [ __ ] [ __ ] thief
oh my god the classic or the-- I think
she's awesome huh who's our first I've
known
I can no you gotta please don't hurt me
okay but he ain't horthy if you're
listening to Captain Bob right now right
no what you look in the mirror look at
the mirror right now okay you should
have let him [ __ ] you should have let
Jimmy O yang nut in your [ __ ] mouth
that's not what else
not my no I know you weren't trying to
say in that away just I'm as your older
brother okay
and as your elder I just need to get
that out there okay you weren't
necessarily wanting to say that that's
coming from my mouth but that infuriates
me man it's it's weird it's next level
infuriating I hear that Chinese men make
the best husbands out of all the other
Asians and that's coming from my best
friend who's Korean really he says that
she would she's more than likely well
amongst the Korean ladies the rumor has
it that Chinese men are the most doting
husbands versus the Korean the weakest
they're the weaker
what Koreans are tough like like you
like I've seen Koreans fight like I I
got yeah like we're talking like we're
just boys we're making fun I'm like it's
grandma whatever we're just Chuck it's
just like threw a fork at me America
yeah I'm like doing with boys man the
[ __ ] yeah you guys don't take [ __ ] from
people
[Music]